this was a glorious spring day in
bedfordshire for the final journey of an
ordinary man who achieved something
truly extraordinary
an raf fly past mark the moment captain
sir tom moore's coffin
was handed over to soldiers from the
yorkshire regiment his home county
captain tom's family had planned this
service and it began with his own voice
on the chart-topping version of you'll
never walk alone
that he recorded with michael ball
at the end of the storm there's a golden
sky
in line with government guidelines only
eight family members could be present
this was his daughter hannah's tribute
we had been so close as a family before
this
but we were thrust even closer together
as the world became enthralled by your
spirit of hope
positivity and resilience
they too saw your belief in kindness
and the fundamental goodness of the
human spirit
and it was that remarkable spirit that
turned this old soldier into a national
treasure
when lockdown brought britain to a
standstill captain tom got moving
100 laps of the garden to mark his 100th
birthday
with the modest aim of raising a few
hundred pounds for the nhs
he ended up bringing in almost 40
million pounds
a nighthood followed in july presented
in person by her majesty the queen
at windsor castle i think the way he he
lived his life in his final 12 months
absolutely spoke volumes of his
character and it's that character that
we
we absolutely recognize as something in
in our soldiers whether they are
veterans or currently serving today his
his generosity is selflessness his
indomitable spirit
the singer michael buble recorded this
version of smile
especially for the funeral service smile
though your heart is aching
and there were plenty of smiles at
captain tom's epitaph
i told you i was old and nod to his
comedy hero spike milligan
[Music]
but it is perhaps his promise that
tomorrow will be a good day
and the hope he gave so many people
through his actions
that will be his greatest legacy and the
brady sky news
in bedfordshire